To make our zero gravity video for "Upside Down and Inside Out,"...
...we flew in a plane that basically goes like this.
Each of these humps is called a "parabola,"...
...and on each parabola what you feel is 20 seconds of double gravity...
...while the plane is throwing you into the air.
Then you feel weightless for about 27 seconds while you go up over the top...
...but kind of sail back towards the ground.
Then at the bottom, the plane catches you again,...
...and you feel 20 more seconds of double gravity.
After the whole maneuver is done, you've lost a lot of altitude...
...so it takes about four or five minutes for the plane...
...to gear back up to do it all over again.
The song itself moves in musical sections that are 21 seconds.
Each verse of the song is 21 seconds.
Each round of the chorus is 21 seconds.
The way we made the 21 seconds of song match the 27 seconds of zero gravity...
...was we slowed the playback of the song down, about 28.5 percent.
Here's what we looked like in real time.
And then when it was done, we sped the whole thing back up,...
...which also combated the kind of drifty, floaty slo-mo effect...
...that everything gets in zero-g.
I mean, it is truly unbelievable that everything just came together.
There were so many variables, so many unknowns, so many challenges.
Basically, I'm still sighing big sighs of relief that it happened.